I'm gonna be honest with you home to bed
last night like what am I gonna do for
Wednesday's video it's I'll figure it
out tomorrow Oh
apocalypse war animation people want me
to do that okay I could do that then the
universe was like you want to do a DC
video huh here you go so I guess the
Snyder cuts happening which is great for
a few reasons not just because
apparently now JK Simmons didn't get
that jacked for nothing I suppose health
is its own reward
there's that this is some solid
entertainment news the Internet's been
clamoring for ever for this so now this
possibility became a reality it's
happening on HBO max that's HBO
streaming service but you know that's a
great bit of marketing right there oh we
have some stiff competition for
streaming services what do we do I don't
know let's get that thing that the
internet so collectively wants enough to
buy billboards and types quick for it's
not a bad idea so this is supposedly a
four and a half hour long cut of the
movie so it's unclear as to whether or
not this is gonna be a four and a half
hour long movie or whether or not it's
gonna be a few hour long episodes or so
the hateful eight extended edition did
that on Netflix it's these four
hour-long episodes of hateful eight that
all lines up to be one movie but in
execution those four hour-long episodes
making up one movie that was a really
great way to do it so whether or not
they're gonna go that way I don't know
but that would make it feel a little
more comic book it's like a comic book
trade each trade is made up of about six
comic books all making up one story kind
of feel like that but hey I'll leave
that up to them but still when this
release the Snyder cut hashtag started
gaining momentum I was like I am curious
what is cut what a bend I don't know
we'll see what happens I'll do a video
about it when there's more to talk about
like today so personally I'm glad I get
to say it it wasn't have to lose let me
build other than money but we've kind of
seen as of late as movies have premiered
on streaming services there is money to
be made there so I think it's a safe
call to release it but in terms of the
legacy what we have to lose what you're
gonna have a Justice League movie that
no one thinks or talks about anymore we
already have that this is the Justice
League movie with guy maybe it'll be
great maybe it'll be crap but I'm just
glad he has his shot to complete his
story he deserves that know glad I don't
have to see YouTube fighting with
Twitter on whether or not the Snyder cut
exists but even then I feel like people
were arguing semantics you know I just
feel like each side was arguing for the
same reality like release the Snyder cut
the Snyder
cut does not exist yeah it does it
totally exists a completed cut of the
Snider cut does not exist will not exist
but there's enough to make the Snider
cut exist which by definition means the
Snider cut doesn't exist but it can
exist again which means it doesn't exist
but it does exist in the capacity that
it can happen a completely cut with all
visual effects editing and
post-production does not exist but it
can exist if they complete it which they
can do so complete it and release the
Snider cut but if they have to complete
it that means technically speaking at
this very moment in this second in
space-time
it doesn't currently exist ergo the
Snider cut does not exist I hate I just
I saw that I was like I think you both
understand the same thing you just look
it's like an unstoppable force met an
immovable object I mean if I'm making my
assessment release the Snider cut just
kind of took all that into consideration
release the Snider cut just sounds
cleaner than finish the visual effects
editing and all post-production on the
Snider cut then release it pretty please
the difference between the Facebook and
Facebook it's cleaner when you have the
director and the actors tweeting
releases Snyder cut you got at least
humor that this might be a reality right
so the Snyder cut is happening it's
coming in 2021 it'll be on HBO max you
worked hard for this one Internet you
celebrate you and joy also Zack Snyder
he should celebrate too I gets to show
his story and Jason Momoa he's been the
most vocal released the bucket that dude
has wanted to see this [ __ ] apparently
he's already seen it he's wanted all of
us to see it so I feel it Momoa thank
you release the [ __ ] what do you think
about this news whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]